Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Jamal Greene, who teaches constitutional
law at Columbia University and also is author
of How Rights Went Wrong Why Our Obsession
with Rights is Tearing America Apart.
It's so great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Good to be here.
Thanks.
So maybe just to frame our conversation, you
know, one of the things I've talked about
over the last few years is that a lot of these
movements that claim to be or are ostensibly
about rights and about staking a claim to
a right, exercising a certain right, they
seem to do this in the absence of an understanding
that with rights come responsibilities and
that the claiming of rights in a vacuum seems
to be untenable and in some cases an impossibility
sort of in modern modern society.
I'd love to kind of first hear your thoughts
a little bit about that and the idea of our
rights, something that we should be exploring
in a vacuum absent any cultural societal reality,
or is that context absolutely crucial to thinking
about rights?
Speaker 5: Well, I certainly think that rights
are embedded within a society.
And and we actually have a very long tradition
in the United States of thinking about rights
and their limits as something that is a collective
exercise.
That's actually how the framers thought about
rights.
But we've gone away from that vision and gotten
to a place where and I think this is where
your political movements come in.
We tend to to use rights as political leverage
because we tend to think about them in almost
absolute terms as as you say, in a vacuum,
kind of disconnected from all else, that once
you claim a right, then you get to win.
Right.
So the whole game becomes, can I claim a right?
Can I get a relevant decision makers sometimes
courts to to say that I have a right.
And that's what's going to win me my political
battle.
And we I think we need to get back to thinking
about rights in political terms, which is
to say in terms of of being part of a society.
Speaker 1: What is a framework where we can
think about situations where rights seemingly
conflict or when we're talking about one's
freedom or rights to do something versus someone
else's freedom or a right to be free of that
something?
What's the framework that we should be applying
to those conflicts?
Speaker 5: Well, one of the things I emphasized
in the book is that rights inherently conflict.
They always conflict.
And you can if you think about your right
to form a society and to pass laws, right
to government is designed to protect rights.
And there's also, of course, another side
where there's individuals who are claiming
particular rights against what government
does.
So there's constantly conflict.
You've got to have a strategy for managing
that conflict.
In the US, our legal system has developed
to a place where the way we live, the way
we manage it, is to kind of pretend it doesn't
exist, pretend the conflict isn't there and
that one side is right and the other side
is wrong.
So you've got to pick who has the right in
any particular case, whereas in actually many
other countries, in fact, most other countries,
the way in which the legal system tends to
respond is through.
I'll use a legalistic term called proportionality.
But what it really means is that you kind
of background the question of who has the
right.
It just assumed that rights exist on both
sides of a lot of legal questions and you
focus much more heavily on what is the government
doing, what kind of problem is it trying to
respond to?
What kind of evidence is it relying on?
What kind of alternatives are available to
it?
Is it acting totally disproportionately or
is it acting basically reasonably?
Those are the kinds of questions that we typically
ask when we're asking about if this just is
this fair.
And those questions are totally consistent
with the notion that that there are rights
involved, because you've got a what I say
in the book is mediate between different claims
of rights on multiple sides of a conflict
and get really factual questions of, well,
what's what's actually going on here.
We don't need to to get into the kind of legalistic
questions of what is the First Amendment mean
or what does the Constitution say.
Those questions don't get us very far in answering
questions about rights conflicts.
We've got to get into the into the factual
details.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, to take a case, maybe
many in my audience will be familiar with
this infamous gay wedding cake case from from
the state of Colorado.
One interpretation of that would be that it's
a question of the right of a business owner
to make decisions about how they want to operate
their business and the right of the couple
wanting the cake not to be discriminated against
on the basis of sexual orientation.
It might it could be framed as a right versus
a right.
All sorts of different participants have reframed
it where there's other ways to think about
it.
One could say, well, it's a judge or jury
choosing as to which whose rights reigns supreme.
But is it not that simple?
Speaker 5: I think it's not that simple and
it's a it's a fascinating case because I think
it really does kind of burrow down on this
on this problem where I actually think there's
even more than two sets of rights involved.
So there's the rights of a baker who wants
to to decide which which wedding cakes for.
Right.
And he's claiming a religious right and also
a free speech.
Right.
Because his cakes are really artistic.
So.
Right.
He thinks that it's a way of speaking.
There's the right of the couple to to not
be discriminated against, as you say, David.
And then there's the right of the people of
Colorado passed a law that says don't discriminate
on the basis of sexual orientation.
So they've got rights to at least the way
I frame it.
So there's rights on all sides.
And you could think of it in the most kind
of binary terms as a judge or jury has got
to pick, you know, whose rights count.
But there actually are lot, lots of overlap
in how each of the sides in that case understood
the rights of the other side.
So the couple actually believed that a baker
can choose whether to bake a cake for someone
he ideologically disagrees with.
He can decide not to bake a cake.
And the couple agreed with that.
The baker agreed that he actually can't discriminate
on the basis of sexual orientation in baking
his cakes.
He didn't claim a First Amendment right to
avoid discrimination.
What the disagreement was, was a much more
narrow disagreement about whether refusing
to bake a cake for a same sex wedding counted
as discrimination on the basis of sexual orientation.
Because the baker said, I don't care who my
customers are, I just don't want to participate
in this wedding.
So that's an ideological dispute.
According to him, he's not actually discriminating
against any people.
And the couple said, well, no, if this had
been an opposite sex wedding, you would have
you would have baked the cake.
And so that is discrimination.
But that's actually a pretty narrow conflict.
And what I'm trying to suggest in the book
is that judges really need to focus on on
the narrow part of the conflict rather than
trying to decide, you know, do we care more
about religious freedom or do we care more
about equality for same sex couples?
Those are values, conflicts that we're not
going to resolve in a court case and shouldn't
try to resolve.
But we can actually get much closer together
if we focus on individual details.
Speaker 1: In fact, I guess that's the tricky
thing, where it's very common that you will
have a case that starts with what appears
to be a decision or a conflict between some
broader values about how society or an economy
or a culture should operate.
And by the time it gets to either the initial
court decision or even on an appeal, some
subsequent court's decision, it ends up being
something very, very narrow.
And I think to some degree, that is a source
of frustration for many people who would like
to have these broader issues resolved, sort
of like once and for all.
And it doesn't happen because the courts end
up very narrowly making making a decision,
as you point out.
How should the broader questions be dealt
with?
Because when they're dealt with so-called
democratically, either by by, you know, a
ballot initiative or by the legislatures that
we elect often, it's still not permanent in
that then it's undone at the next opportunity.
I mean, how should a society deal with the
broader question?
Speaker 5: Well, the broader questions of
values, conflicts, I think the first thing
I'll say is they shouldn't be resolved by
courts.
OK, and this is the this is it writes, conflicts
are ultimately political conflicts or conflicts
between people who have fundamental disagreements
with one another.
And it's OK to have fundamental disagreements
That's what makes us human.
And in some ways, the core of the book is
to say, look, the reason we disagree about
rights is not because one of us is right and
the other is because some of us are angels
and others devils, because we're different
people.
We have different values, different commitments.
And when you when you overlay a legal system
onto that kind of disagreement, the legal
system has to figure out how do you construct
rules that enable people to live together
and to stay invested within the constitutional
system.
So we actually celebrate uncertainty, at least
to a degree.
I celebrate not resolving rights conflicts
for all time because that that that means
that the Constitution doesn't protect or doesn't
care about one or the other side of really
important values, conflicts.
I don't think that's the way a legal system
should operate.
I think you try to mediate those conflicts
through politics.
And when I say politics, I don't always mean
legislative politics or ballot initiatives.
I mean other kinds of institutions.
Journalists are are engaged in acts of politics.
When we go to when we have social media conversation,
that's politics.
Schools are engaged in forms of politics.
Politics is is is is is constructing a political
culture, a culture of understanding what the
core of our disagreements might be, understanding
the perspective of other sides and trying
to work towards a solution.
And that's what that's what political negotiation
looks like.
And that that again, that doesn't necessarily
happen in legislatures, although that's the
sort of ultimate that's the ultimate, you
know, power wielder is the legislature.
But before you get to the legislature, there's
a whole lot of political conversation that
has to happen that gets shut off.
If we think that the way to resolve our political
conflicts is to give them to courts who are
going to make kind of legalistic, abstract
decisions that don't get us very far to addressing
our conflicts.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask about,
you know, during the run up to the 2020 election,
I received a lot of emails from viewers and
listeners, particularly in Europe, who said,
you know, I'm following this election in the
United States and I'm struck by how much talk
there is of people asserting rights, the discussion
of my right to free speech, my right to vote,
my right to a gun, et cetera, saying that
in in their countries, this idea of asserting
rights just is not a it's not a narrative
in elections.
And that they found that there was they were
curious about like, how did this become such
a thing in American politics where people
are constantly talking about rights and asserting
rights?
Is there some particular history to that in
the United States that we can point to about
how this issue of the asserting of rights
became such a political discussion that in
other countries it simply is not so?
Speaker 5: So I'll say a couple of things.
One is, is that in Europe, they do care about
rights, but they just don't necessarily think
of rights as kind of trumps that kind of overcome
everything else.
And that's what's really, I think, different
about our political culture.
And I think that I try to tell the story in
the in the book and kind of the first third
of the book.
It doesn't come from the founding, which is
what we often tell ourselves.
The founders had a much more communitarian
view of rights than than modern Americans
do.
It really comes out of the 1960s in the post
civil rights era legacy.
And it's a it's a it's a complex story.
But what it boils down to is, is a history
with race and with the particular pathologies,
the particular problem of of people who are
being racially discriminated against in overt
ways, being kind of the paradigm of rights
in America, right to the core right is the
right against racial discrimination.
And that's not something you mediate.
It's not something where you say, well, you
know, let's see what the segregationists think
and then we'll see what other people think.
It doesn't lend itself to mediation because
one side of that dispute is completely bad
faith, the oppressive, abusive actor.
But you can't associate all of government
with you know, any time I write is at stake.
That means the government's being abusive
or oppressive.
That's not most rights.
That's not most rights conflicts.
And so I think we need a language in which
we can talk about ordinary political conflict
that doesn't take the form of this is let's
see if this is just like Jim Crow or let's
see if this is just like McCarthyism.
We've got to take rights conflicts on their
facts and actually think about what the government's
trying to accomplish and whether it's something
that is considered to be legitimate within
our tradition.
Speaker 1: Very of very well said the book,
as we've been mentioning.
Is how rights went wrong, why our obsession
with rights is tearing America apart.
We've been talking with the author of the
book, Professor Jamal Greene.
It's so great to have you on.
I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Great to be here.
I enjoyed the conversation.
Thanks.
Speaker 1: Yesterday was a super interesting
media criticism day, we had guests on both
Fox News and Newsmax call out Fox News and
Newsmax for their perpetuating lies on the
air.
Later, we'll look at Newsmax.
But let's start with FOX News.
These are really, really good clips.
Randi Weingarten is a lawyer, a labor activist,
labor leader, president of the American Federation
of Teachers, member of the AFL-CIO.
Fox News's Martha MacCallum brought Randi
Weingarten on to talk about critical race
theory being taught in schools.
This segment is not going to be about critical
race theory.
I just did a whole segment, two shows ago
on critical race theory.
You can find it on the Friday podcast or on
YouTube.
So this is not the topic today.
That was the topic of the segment we're going
to look at and check out how Randi just goes
right at Fox while being interviewed by Martha
MacCallum for them spreading misinformation.
And Martha MacCallum doesn't like it.
Speaker 6: Big believer in celebrating diversity
in action and actually looking at and helping
look at people's lived experience.
But if you're really talking about misinformation
now, Martha, and I hope you are, I really
would hope that Fox would really look at what
happened in this election and how we can,
because every social studies teacher is wrestling
with this discern fact from fiction.
We have to do that.
Speaker 4: So, yeah, we have well, we have
a president President Biden was elected in
twenty twenty.
I think that all of that is is quite clear.
So I'm not sure why you are so concerned with
with that part, with that particular moment
in history.
Every election is significant.
Nobody is hiding anything under any rocks
here.
But but I do wonder, you know, the fact that
you have
Speaker 1: to Martha MacCallum is just so
confused about why Randi Weingarten would
bring up telling the truth about the election.
Oh, I don't know.
Maybe because of the months of spreading and
inviting guests to spread disinformation about
the election, which partially played a role
in getting things to the fever pitch that
culminated on January 6th with the Trump riots.
Maybe that has something to do with it, Martha.
And then this is really great.
Even though Martha MacCallum immediately tries
to start talking over Randi Weingarten in
her next opportunity, Randi comes right back
and does the same thing on the topic of vaccination
reporting.
And this time Martha MacCallum gets more upset.
Speaker 6: I would hope, Fox says, to all
these people that don't want the vaccines,
that think there's a problem, why don't you
and I do things together to get our kids back
to school?
This is what we need to do.
We have to stop the misinformation.
We have to stop the disinformation efforts,
Speaker 4: as you know.
And you know, as you know, many of those students
were back without being vaccinated.
And the CDC said it wasn't required for teachers
or students to be vaccinated to go back to
school.
So children are a separate issue.
Every family across America is going to make
that decision about their children.
We know that these are going to be widely
available for them, which is great.
So people have that option.
Speaker 1: That indignant attitude is just
too much.
Fox hosts get absolutely exasperated when
they are confronted by guests for what Fox
News does, says and puts out on the airwaves.
And we've covered those incidents before.
She got defensive really quickly.
And Randi Weingarten really getting under
Martha McCallum's skin there.
And if you're watching these clips, rather
than just listening, you may notice the facial
expression change just instantly on Martha
McCallum's face when the call-out starts to
happen.
If guests did this more regularly on Fox News,
I think Fox would have to change its approach.
Maybe they'd have to switch to prerecording
interviews to prevent this.
Maybe they wouldn't even have these guests
on.
I don't know if that's better.
Right.
To some to some degree, it's good to have
people who talk sense on Fox News.
It might pierce someone's filter bubble or
echo chamber.
I don't know.
But that's kind of my question.
Like, is there a downside to this?
Presumably it's the guests won't be invited
back.
Maybe Fox News will further even limit the
voices that are allowed on the channel.
But if guests started doing this more regularly,
I think it would be absolutely great.
And amazingly, this was not the only instance
of a guest calling out the network on that
network yesterday.
This example was from Fox News.
I now have one to look at from Newsmax